[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute eine
richtig hübsche und sehr sehr leckere
Mousse Torte vertraut mir es ist
einfacher als es aussieht das
Endergebnis ist echt traumhaft schön
aber die Zubereitung ist wirklich super
easy lasst euch nicht abschrecken selbst
wenn ihr Anfänger seid und ganz neu in
dem Bereich seid und nicht so oft backt
macht einfach noch mal eine Anleitung es
wird euch gelingen das verspreche ich
euch und ich starte jetzt auch direkt
mit der Zubereitung die Zutaten findet
ihr wie immer hier unten in der Infobox
unter dem Titel einfach aufklappen und
dann könnt ihr euch das ganze
screenshotten wie ihr seht habe ich hier
äh ganz viele Kaufland Zutaten denn die
Zutaten für dieses Rezept findet ihr
alle bei Kaufland also müsst ihr nicht
verschiedenste Märkte abklappern genau
habt ihr alles aus einer Hand ich nehme
jetzt hier ganz einfache Butterkekse die
werden jetzt hier fein gemixt da gebe
ich dann gleich noch Backkakao dazu
und werde geschmolzene Butter hinzugeben
[Musik]
so unser Boden ist schon fertig das hat
keine zwei Minuten gedauert und jetzt
brauchen wir so ein kleines Konstrukt
und zwar habe ich hier mein Tortenring
den werde ich auf 18 cm einstellen und
damit ihr später einfach auch optisch so
eine so ein richtig schönen
gleichmäßigen glattenrand habt benötigt
jetzt tortenrandfolie das Benutzen die
ganz gerne in der Patisserie und da wird
einfach so den Durchmesser entsprechend
die Folie mit der Schere abgeschnitten
und dann in den Tortenring gelegt damit
ihr eben später einfach auch wenn ihr
eure must-torte komplett fertig habt
damit ihr einen wunderschönen geraden
Abschluss habt dass das kriegt ihr nicht
hin wenn ihr das nicht verwendet wenn
sonst ist alles so gruselig und die
reißt euch da ein bisschen was weg und
das schützt euch eben davor
[Musik]
den Boden habe ich jetzt einfach in den
Tortenring gegeben und dann mit einem
glasrücken angedrückt ich habe jetzt
hier auch mein cakeboard unten drunter
normalerweise mache ich es auch gerne so
dass ich es direkt auf meiner
Servierplatte oder Tortenplatte dann
zubereite aber in dem Fall wird das
jetzt ab und zu mal in den Kühlschrank
gelegt und in der Regel ist es dann
schon sehr viel Platz was da verloren
geht im Kühlschrank und da habe ich
jetzt den cakeboard das gebe ich jetzt
auch bis zur Weiterverarbeitung in den
Kühlschrank und ich zeige euch jetzt wie
ihr die erste Moosschicht macht bis
gleich
so ich habe jetzt hier kalte Schlagsahne
das ist unter anderem die Basis für
unsere Moos und die gebe ich jetzt
komplett obwohl es für alle drei
Schichten die Sahne Menge schon ist gebe
ich dir jetzt einmal komplett in die
Rührschüssel meiner Küchenmaschine
übrigens hier auch nichts Warmes dran
also es wird nicht gerade irgendwie warm
gespült oder so es funktioniert wirklich
nur wenn alles kalt ist ihr könnt auch
gerne zur Sicherheit schneebesenaufsatz
und Rührschüssel in den Kühlschrank
geben für 5 Minuten einfach dass ihr
euch sicher seid denn dann lässt sie
sich gut aufschlagen und wir schlagen
das ganze jetzt hier auch ohne Ende fest
damit wir eben diese moosartige
Konsistenz bekommen und machen da gleich
Gelatine rein aber dazu sage ich euch
gleich noch was
und dann können wir im Anschluss auch
schon für alle drei Schichten jeweils
200 Gramm Sahne schon mal separat
aufteilen denn jeder Becher ist halt wie
gesagt für jede Schicht und so haben wir
einmal die Arbeit und machen das später
dann nicht separat sondern haben einmal
alles zusammen aufgeschlagen
[Musik]
so wir starten ja mit der Zeit
bitterschicht und da habe ich die
Schokolade schon fein gehackt ihr könnt
auch Kuvertüre nehmen ich habe jetzt
heute Schokolade da und jetzt gebe ich
das hin mein Schmelztopf da macht ihr am
allerbesten ein Wasserbad und zwar für
alle drei Schichten denn da seid ihr
einfach auf Nummer sicher dass euch die
Schokolade nicht verbrennt ihr könntet
notfalls wirklich auch in der Mikrowelle
machen aber damit die ganz ganz
vorsichtig deswegen bin ich immer bei
solchen Geschichten entfernt vom
Wasserbad dafür einfach Wasser in einem
Topf richtig schön aufkochen
anschließend hat wieder runterschalten
so und dann so ein Schmelztopf einfach
drüberlegen das sollte dann nicht ganzes
Wasser berühren und dann reicht quasi
die Hitze das fängt schon an zu
schmelzen und reicht die Hitze damit das
richtig schön langsam schmelzen kann in
der Zwischenzeit nehmen wir uns unsere
Gelatine und geben die hier in kaltes
Wasser für 5 Minuten das darf dann so
ein bisschen einweichen anschließend
ausdrücken und in lauwarme Milch geben
die Milch einfach in die Mikrowelle
erwärmen und da drin dann auflösen und
dann zeige ich euch wie es weitergeht
diese gelatine ist übrigens vom Rind und
halal und die gibt's auch bei Kaufland
in der Abteilung
[Musik]
so ich muss sagen dass das Ganze echt
wunderbar funktioniert wenn ihr das
alles so ein bisschen gleichzeitig timet
wenn ihr das Schmelzen das parallel
schon mal die Gelatine einweicht feste
ausdrücken sonst mache ich es auch gerne
Tropfen nass wenn ich irgendwie die
Gelatine in der Pfanne erwärme aber in
dem Fall feste ausdrücken für mich geben
und dann die Schokolade direkt mit dazu
geben die Masse ist jetzt noch lauwarm
natürlich dürft ihr ganz heiße Sachen
jetzt nicht zu Sahne geben aber ihr
könnt das jetzt hier wenn ihr euch
unsicher seid lasst es euch noch zwei
drei Minuten stehen aber ihr könnt sie
noch hier relativ lauwarm bis fast kalt
zu Sahne geben allerdings muss die Masse
jetzt noch flüssig sein um sie mit der
Sahne verbinden zu können deshalb ist es
ja ausnahmsweise erlaubt lauwarmes zu
Sahne zu geben und die Gelatine macht
die ganze Masse ja gleich auch schön
fest bzw am Ende nach der ganzen
Kühlzeit auch schön moosartig so und
jetzt einfach hier mit einem Teigschaber
richtig schön unterheben alles
rauskratzen was geht und dann geben wir
das auf unseren Keksboden
[Musik]
so die erste Schicht sollte jetzt
natürlich schon mal ein bisschen fest
werden zumindest so fest dass wir die
zweite Schicht oben drüber gehen können
ohne dass ich jetzt die zwei Schichten
miteinander vermischen die Zeiten blende
ich euch ein denn wenn Ihr Platz habt im
Gefrierfach könnt ihr das ganze da
zumindest jetzt fürs Schichten
beschleunigen später muss das ganze
sowieso im Kühlschrank fest werden aber
zur Wartezeit und zu Kühlzeit sage ich
euch ganz am Ende noch was wenn wir alle
drei Schichten haben aber wie gesagt
einfach dass die Oberfläche so ein
bisschen fester ist und wie die zweite
Schicht oben drüber machen können und
das ist eigentlich exakt dasselbe nur
diesmal mit Vollmilchschokolade gerade
hatten mehr Zartbitter bzw bitter und
jetzt nehmen wir Vollmilch und das exakt
gleiche Prinzip und im dritten Schritt
machen wir das gleiche dann auch noch
mit weißer Schokolade
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich noch einen Tipp für euch
versucht es möglichst mittig zu
platzieren und dann nach außen zu
streichen ihr habt ja gerade vielleicht
auch gesehen ich nehme mir da auch gerne
mal Küchenrolle zur Hand und streicht
den Rand falls irgendwas übersteht noch
mal gerade damit einfach optisch von
außen auch schön aussieht und jetzt habe
ich hier einfach die streichpalette weil
dann kann ich mit dem ganzen Arm
reingehen und dann richtig schön langsam
nach außen verstreichen und ich gebe dir
wie gesagt bei mir ins Gefrierfach weil
es schneller geht aber selbst wenn es im
Kühlschrank lagert eigentlich sind das
gar nicht so die extrem Wartezeiten weil
ihr immer so 10 Minuten vor Ende der
Kühlzeit anfangen könnt mit der nächsten
Schicht
[Musik]
so ich muss sagen das läuft wie am
Schnürchen die zweite Schicht ist jetzt
auch schön fest an der Oberfläche die
dritte habe ich gerade vorbereitet die
ist jetzt richtig schön schneeweiß und
ich werde jetzt noch ein bisschen
Vanilleextrakt hinzufügen das ist
optional aber es macht geschmacklich
halt echt was aus und ich finde geradezu
weißen Schicht so ein bisschen
Vanilleextrakt ist ja schon sehr
intensiv da braucht ihr gar nicht so
viel wie gesagt das ist optional aber
ich will dass es einfach rundum perfekt
wird sowohl optisch als auch
geschmacklich so und das gebe ich dann
auch noch oben drüber und jetzt gebe ich
es nicht mehr ins Gefrierfach also ihr
könnt ja auch die ganze Zeit halt den
Kühlschrank verwenden und nicht den
nicht das Gefrierfach aber ich mache an
der Stelle so weil das jetzt die letzte
Schicht ist ich streiche sie nur noch
glatt und dann kommt sie bei mir bis
morgen in den Kühlschrank ich lass sie
ganz in Ruhe er hatten erkalten und ähm
macht dann morgen weiter mit meinen
wunderschönen Entzündung mit dem Test
allerdings muss ich sagen dass wenn ihr
jetzt keine Zeit habt reichen da auch
zwei Stunden im Kühlschrank aus weil
wenn ich Gelatine einmal kalt ist dann
sitzt alles alles fest und das ist kein
Problem aber wenn die Zeit habt dann
gibt dem ganzen ruhig einmal die ganze
Nacht
[Musik]
diese Torte ist so hübsch dass wir
eigentlich gleich noch mehr Videos und
Fotos machen
das ist mein Problem die ist so mutig
dass wir so glatt von der gabelfeld ja
was ist das eigentlich genau
es ist wirklich Luft Luft im Mund Luft
lecker schmecken
und ganz am Ende hat man noch sowas
knackiges aber so richtig wenig und
leicht dass man sagt dieses luftige
zusammen mit diesem knackigen Boden
nach oben steigt so
auf mich
Schokolade dann ja unten der Boden hat
man sich noch so einen weißen knack aber
sowas
traumhaft geil alle Komponenten im Mund
zu seiner luftigen geilen Masse
richtig mit dieser Torte kann man
richtige Herzen erobern aber wirklich
das meine ich vollkommen ernst gerade
ganz natürlich wir wollten zwischendurch
mal die Zeit stoppen wenn ich nicht
mitfilmen würde wenn ich alles parallel
mache und eine Stunde unter weit unter
eine Stunde eine Dreiviertelstunde
vielleicht maximum bin ich mit Zeit
lassen und total langsam bin Hammer das
schmeckt so wie so ein richtig leckerer
Mousse Pudding den du willst am liebsten
so im Laden haben aber da gibt's nicht
ja genau das das muss es mal das das
müssen wir mit dem Kaffee
übertrieben lecker
also ich muss sagen dadurch dass wir
jetzt auch diese tortenrandfolie hatten
guck mal wie perfekt das aussieht das
bekommt ihr nicht ohne Tortenrand zu
leben das muss ja an der Stelle noch mal
sagen
die ganze Optik wäre
voll schön
12 Millionen Bildern
ein kleines Stück Schokolade so habe ich
mir auch gedacht machen
okay
wenn euch das gefallen hat und wir sehen
uns dann beim nächsten Rezept ne tschüss
[Musik]